threat of the military is back
daily mail reports freedom convoy votes
to stay on the bridge and defy trudeau's
order to clear it by 7 pm the prime
minister threatened that everything is
on the table including using the
military after a call with biden to
discuss americans backing the protest
this is this is an insane escalation
first of all when i read this morning
that joe biden
contacted canada the administration was
like we're going to help you with this
and you got to shut it down i was like
wow
somebody tweeted that the u.s should
invade canada i mean i know i tweeted
that but someone tweeted it before me
and i it's a joke right we're not gonna
but now i mean the idea that the us
would get involved in a canadian protest
but like we talked about it could be
payback for the 1819 invasion right
that's it
yeah biden was like no there's a chance
well i mean he was around he saw it
happen that's exactly right poor guys
right yeah you can't blame the senate
actually back then yeah
this is like an example of them trying
to shut down something that's trying to
shut down something that's trying to
shut down something you know they're
trying to shut down the combos trying to
shut down the government which is trying
to shut down the people's access to
their stuff but i love the fact that you
know biden and the dems they want to get
involved and try and shut down this in
canada but yet where were they during
the 2020 riots when they're out there
encouraging it and they're out there
saying we should get in the face of
politicians and we should why isn't
there more widespread civil unrest i
mean this was the rhetoric they were
using back then because it was
beneficial to them and now all of a
sudden it was like no no no we have to
be interventionist exactly it's because
it works it's because they say these
things and their voter base doesn't
change that that people will keep voting
for them is is astonishing to me well
and the fact that we've seen i mean look
secretary gates who was the secretary of
defense under the obama biden
administration you know he had that live
interview and they asked him about joe
biden in foreign policy said look joe
biden's the only person i know he's been
100 wrong on foreign policy i mean this
is his own secretary of defense right so
now you've got him doing the exact same
thing and democrats they constantly talk
about you know interventionism i mean
look at us we're involved in russia
ukraine now we're now looking at getting
involved in canada but why can't we even
secure our own american borders and
focus on an america first agenda
thinking about our people first that's
what i have a question about i think the
rest of the american people do as well
yeah ever since we started i mean i
don't know how you feel about the
federal reserve and the whole
international banking car i don't know
if you called a cartel or a scheme or
what like the bank of international
settlements in switzerland it goes
through the federal reserve of new york
the bank of england and the bank of
australia and then basically seems to be
it's a swiss ba it's going through a
swiss bank that's not an american thing
and so i i have a feeling they just
don't really care about american
democracy american people are a
byproduct and well well i correct people
on this by the way i hate when everyone
wants to say oh america is the longest
serving democracy no
correct everyone who says this we are a
constitutional republic
people need to understand the difference
between what it is to be a democracy and
what it is to be a a constitutional
republic we have democratic elections
but we are a constitutional republican i
always not to interrupt but i always
like to try and correct people on that
because you know that's a really big
deal are we a democratic republic
no we are a constitutional republic we
are based if you're a true you know what
i consider to be an american who is a
constitutionalist who believes in our
freedoms values and things that we stand
for the things that we're supposed to be
protecting which is why we have a
military and things like this then you
understand what it is to be a
constitutional republic we have
democratic processes but we are actually
a constitutional republican because
within the republic they use democracy
to decide yes or no yeah what we elect
our representatives that's the
democratic process and then they decide
the yes or no through a democratic
process again the reason they do this
trick it's a language trick it always is
and it works
they keep saying our democracy our
democracy because they want a direct
democracy right because a direct
democracy is easy to manipulate 100 i
guess
look at this way
let's say you have uh 100 people
and there's there's there's four
different categories of political
ideology a b c and d
you need only win
two of those
factions plus one to control the system
that means that group a might be in
favor of policies one and two group b
could be in favor of policies three and
four
you can come out and advocate against
one of the group's interests as long as
you convince another group so basically
it's kind of you know i don't know if
people can follow me on this one the
idea is direct democracy you will have a
majority unhappy population and you will
be able to control them and they can't
do anything about it i'll give you
actually here's a simple example
is what i was told about egypt during
the second revolution
the reason it happened was because there
were there was uh like eight political
parties or something like that and the
muslim brotherhood made up like 20
percent of the country a minority but
because of the way they do their
elections
they got the most votes of any group the
country is then ruled by the minority so
it's not the exact same election system
it's the same thing in iraq and it's the
same thing that's why you continue to
see this political turmoil because what
happens the very people who try to
overthrow the government then say well
wait a second that doesn't work through
force we'll create a political party and
get enough people that support us in the
elections and then they basically take
over a sectarian democracy
yep
yeah we don't we don't want direct
democracy i've seen it i've seen it play
out it's uh it results in the in the
impoverished marginalized people being
severely oppressed and anyone who claims
otherwise is outright lying to you and
that's why we have an electoral college
that's why we are a republic and to
quote benjamin franklin though it may be
apocryphal he said democracy or he said
democracy is two wolves and a lamb
voting on what's for lunch a republic is
a well-armed lamb contesting the vote no
i mean it's true a direct democracy is
really just a i would say a cleaner
more systematized version of mob rule
well so let's let's talk about this in
the context of what's happening in
canada then if you've got uh you know so
so trudeau says it's a fringe minority
and the media comes out so it's only 500
truckers it's a fringe minority now some
have said it's 50 000 truckers i mean
either way 50 000 it's a lot of people
but not relative to the 30 plus million
citizens of canada
so is that a problem then
as as populations grow denser and denser
you need a smaller smaller and smaller
percentage of the population to enact
change through even non-violence of
disobedience now is that fundamentally
wrong well you see it on twitter the
density of our interactions have have
concluded or have condensed uh on online
and social networking we're all packed
together now and you see a small fringe
group of psychopaths can completely warp
the narrative overnight that's very
dangerous but it seems like it's also
human nature so so i assume we just
gotta have to deal with it coming i mean
this is this is the challenge of our
life or one of them i mean i personally
i don't really see it there's a big
problem with this i mean look they're
they're doing a non-violent protest it's
it's their right i mean look if this is
in america the one of the things that
you know i fought for when i was in
uniform was for our constitutional
liberties and freedoms and one of that
is freedom of speech and freedom to
protest and freedom you know i'm not
talking about the types of quote-unquote
protests that the democrats were
labeling when they were thinking that
rioting and tearing down chanel stores
in downtown new york on fifth avenue was
was was protesting i mean or i always
love that that picture where it's like
the cnn guy with the fire like blazing
behind him he's like well it's a mostly
peaceful protest
fiery but most famous
literally this is what they kind of i
mean look at the end of the day i think
that it is very healthy
and i think that i enjoy the fact when
america or any nation rises together to
show just like with us that we are the
majority we the people not we the
government i think that something that
is really inspiring and something that i
was you know was worth fighting for
because that's what we want to maintain
is those freedoms liberties and rights
it's a good day you know constantly
seeing the victories of these truckers
there was a there's a viral post going
around we've talked about it how
you know people are saying it's a
workers uprising why is the left opposed
to this because the mask is off
the left they're fascists they're
overtly fascist they're pro-corporate
pro-government they've always been they
just didn't like that donald trump was
the person in charge of one branch one
branch
and and he barely could could anything
done because of this the muck in the
mire and the sludge and the swamp not to
say that everything he did was good he
did some bad things and it wasn't just a
love attack you had the republicans who
were part of the establishment part of
the swamp who are also stabbing them in
the back i mean the very people who was
writing the coattails of president
trump's conservative movement are the
same people who are secretly stabbing
him behind because they wanted to
maintain status quo and why because they
were getting paid off by big lobby they
were getting help by corporate they
weren't really wanting the america first
agenda they wanted the power elite
status quo that they had yep i was
thinking a few days ago about corruption
and then i thought i think we need
corruption in the system if you have a
system with no corruption that means
it's an authoritarian crackdown on
everything i disagree
i i actually think the problem with
authoritarianism is not so much that you
have a strong authority structure it's
that the people on top don't have to
follow any of those rules
and you know the funny part a lot of
times it's not even that you know
someone's doing something which is quote
unquote corrupt what they're doing is
they're finding the great areas to
continue to live upon and they basically
go well i never gave money to x i gave
it to y and y gave it to z and z gave it
to b and you know they try to find these
little loopholes and i think those are
the things that you know government
should be spending more time on looking
at legislation that one improves the
betterment of life i'm all about limited
government about limited taxes and
freedom of speech and our second
amendment rights etc etc but you know at
the end of the day what i want to see is
this government who are basically
shutting down these loopholes and not
spending 90 of their time sitting there
just voting on continuation bills yeah
maybe there's evil corruption and good
corruption like if you have a computer
software program it's a virus and it's
destroying everything and you corrupt
the virus is that like a good line about
yeah yeah if you corrupt the virus
program and it no longer works then
you've stopped the virus you did good
corruption to a system
i'm not sure about that no we were
talking about this earlier destruction
can be a good thing so for instance
we're talking about is it right to kill
you know even a bug or an animal well
sometimes you go hunting because the
deer population grows to goes out of
control you cull the the herd otherwise
they would destroy the ecosystem and
then everyone suffers yeah so sometimes
you have to you know yeah and i talked
about this with regards to trophy
hunting as an example right so i went
out and people were saying like how how
cruel it is to kill these you know large
trophy elks things like that what they
don't realize is is that a lot of times
you killing those elks at their prime is
the most humane thing you can do because
what ends up happening is a younger buck
essentially challenges them kicks them
out and they end up wandering by
themselves alone until they end up
falling dead so you know look there's uh
something to be said about this i mean i
grew up in a very kind of i guess just
above the poverty level you know kind of
family and so hunting for us was a
staple in order to fill our deep freeze
i mean bus buying 150 deep freeze to put
on our back patio was a lot cheaper than
trying to buy the meat that we would
require for the whole year well yeah and
also if you if you go hunting what
you're doing is refusing to subsidize
factory farming in a lot of instances
and so people talk all day and night
about how cruel we treat our animals in
this country we're the most reality is
yeah but but also on top of that i mean
hunting if it's an animal you're gonna
eat is one of the most humane ways to
obtain it because like you said you're
preventing a far more cruel death i
think a lot of people have illusions
about what nature is actually like
because they've never spent any time in
it oh my gosh and it's not beautiful or
i mean it is beautiful
yeah it's beautiful exactly it's
beautiful but it's very painful and so
yeah hunting an animal giving them a
quick death so that you can consume them
i mean you have people
they literally think that you know uh
food is just wrapped in a package and
sat in a grocery store i mean we're so
removed from the process of agriculture
i mean i think that's the biggest thing
and i'm a huge agriculture advocate
right so i'm one of those guys i believe
that food security and national security
goes hand in hand i think that we need
to look at more production domestically
i think we need to support agricultural
sector here domestically and i think
that stopping like drop shipments and
importations that are actually you know
hurting our local farmers is not part of
the american first agenda but you know
again people are too far removed from
what it is to have a proper food like
source yeah i'm not sure i'm sure you
guys may have seen this but if not i'll
bring it to your attention years ago i
believe this is from the 80s there's a
newspaper clipping from that era which
which sort of went viral at that time
and it is still floating around but it
was somebody writing into a newspaper
and they said i couldn't believe that
you published an op-ed from a hunter he
should have just gone to the grocery
store and gotten his food
from people who didn't harm animals to
get it which is hysterical um but i mean
i hear what you're saying about food
security and i think part of the problem
is people in power again they know that
if the food becomes more scarce they're
not going to be the one starving to
death which is sort of what i was
alluding to earlier ian when i said the
issue isn't necessarily an authority
structure it's when the people at the
top are above the authority structure
and they don't have to follow the rules
i think when they're on the same playing
field as the average person they're much
more cautious about which laws they're
willing so maybe the corrupt top is
forcing people to become corrupt to
change that corruption or whatever okay
what you're saying thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you